are you ready
for One Last Ride
[Music]
I'll fly away together
into the forever
[Music]
and beautiful sky
well I wanted to replace Chris Pratt
after the first movie but I think the
audience got used to him playing the
character so you know and I think Jack
Russell's gonna be shooting some of the
time so I didn't know that yeah I'm just
finding that out I'm really glad that
really hard and Marvel really fought me
on it oh okay he'd been awesome
yeah should I go one ingredient that I
needed to bring was just the perfect
medium spray tan
that was one yeah on your on your hand
on my hands
and potentially my forearms and my neck
and my decolletage kind of creepy the
way you do that it's kind of like Gollum
yeah
uh you know I think the the ingredient
the main ingredient that we had to bring
was James he's like the the main he's
the main course and so you know him his
imagination and you really see that in
this film in in volume three it's it's
the deepest look into the the strange
caverns of this man's mind and and uh
his love for Animals his love for her
friends his his concern for compassion
uh it all it's all right there on on the
screen and it's it's really incredible I
was excited about bringing pop music
from the first movie the second movie
and kind of keeping that as a part of
the Guardians franchise
tell you something
Star-Lord
yeah Hooked on a Feeling was almost the
opening scene so it was really between
come and get your love and Hooked on a
Feeling for me I don't remember exactly
why but I think I just at the end of the
day felt it was a better song to dance
to and as far as the choreography goes
we didn't really the only thing that was
choreographed was this this thing when
he dances underneath the title because I
had a very specific way that I thought
that should be yeah but other than that
he like he's like I actually hire a you
know choreographer or something yeah
certainly around like the final dance
sequence I was like should we do should
I hire a dance consultant yeah something
or like not that you know the final
dance off but yeah we just shot a bunch
of stuff and we listened to the music
and danced around and there you got a
couple of shots where I slide across the
floor oh yeah the sliding that those
were yeah like stunted out with the
harness where I was going to slide but I
wanted to be like a real guy dancing and
not uh you know choreographed piece yeah
I thought if we got a you know Dance
Crew I prefer it would have just it
looked a little rest area it was really
fun it was really fun yeah yeah it was
early on so there was a certain part of
me that couldn't let go and enjoy myself
while making the first film because I
was really concerned about doing a good
job like I it wasn't until probably the
third movie that I could relax enough to
enjoy the process and didn't feel like I
was
having to prevent myself from being
fired or something you've seen a lot
more relaxed on the second movie though
did I yeah way more relaxed I mean
because you had done you know Jurassic
World by that point you had done this
movie people embraced you as a character
so you definitely seemed more relaxed on
the second film
I formed the Guardians
met a girl fell in love well I think you
know what was interesting about the
second film is it's only two months you
know time wise it was only a couple
months after the first movie uh although
for the audience it was two years later
for us it was just a couple months later
for the the group and so they're just
getting to know each other they're
really becoming a family at that point I
think they become kind of friends in the
first movie they become start to become
a family in the second movie you know
with Gamora Groot all of them you know
and I think that we see you know that
they Embrace mantis to some degree and
she has this instant friendship with
Drax that is really special and she'll
grow a lot and she changes a lot over
the movies but I think they that's when
they start to become a more of a family
and we see the closeness between quill
and Gamora as well grow in that movie
what's that thing in the real world like
what happens when people stop being
polite and start being real that's like
kind of the theme of the second movie it
feels like we're now choosing to be
together we're not stuck together to do
the circumstance and because we all
because I gave a rousing speech and said
let's care about something bigger than
ourselves let's go okay we do it and we
save xandar and now it's like we're
going to continue to do this right as a
group okay so we make that decision at
the end uh something good something bad
a little bit of both and now we're in
the middle of something good something
about a little bit of both and and you
know we're getting to unders we're
getting to see the other sides of each
other's personalities and starting to
annoy each other and as family does yeah
I think you see and there's a great like
your relationship with Gamora changes a
lot I think there's a big fight scene
that you guys have that we choreographed
pretty specifically that fight scene the
way we're all moving around yeah the
camera's moving and that was you know
but that's so obviously even they're not
admitting it that's a fight between
boyfriend girlfriend that's yeah that is
a relationship fight yeah and then you
fight in the third movie and it is
absolutely not a boyfriend girl from
fight right so Something Something
Different yeah then she came back
came back a total dick oh please he left
out some important information but
that is the gist of it well I knew what
was going to happen somewhat in volume
three and so the one thing I asked the
russos do was to give me the kiss
because they needed to have the kiss
um I forget about this all the time but
I'm like yeah please have them give the
kiss so that we know that they're in a
relationship now we see it at the end of
volume two at one point we had shot a
kiss in volume two and uh and it just
was too much and it was much more
effective when she looks at him at the
end and says some unspoken thing that's
you know what she's seeing and you know
in that moment that she loves him uh and
it's just it's like I think that the
subtle way of the Guardians movies even
though they seem rather over the top at
times
um and so they gave me that kiss the
circumstances really s set up uh the
dynamic for volume three and with the
circumstance being that Gamora that
Peter Quill knows dies and then another
Gamora comes back and uh but it's not
the woman that quill knows is not the
woman who ever met quill or has ever
fallen in love with quill he never saved
her life in the middle of uh space and
they never fought the odds together and
they never had an unspoken thing and so
like this relationship that really
defined quill
and gave him a sense of purpose and and
sense of self is gone and so when she's
gone that means that Quill's lost yeah I
think that you know
we've been really clear that if uh you
know somebody dies in a Guardians movie
they're dead
um yondu dies he's dead so many times
you know in comic books especially you
know people die and come back and die
and come back and it kind of makes death
meaningless and so that makes the
sacrifice the the story Point
meaningless and I think with this it was
you know Gamora died in Infinity war and
she is dead this is not Gamora this is
Gamora but it's a different version of
her and she has different experiences
which makes her a different person
completely and so it was to be able to
play with that Multiverse but at the
same time you know acknowledge that
death does have you know reality to it
within this universe mistakes
I I thought it was beautiful it was an
amazing set the nowhere set is truly
extraordinary yeah we got the piggyback
on Guardians 3 because we shot the
holiday special at the same time so we
didn't we got the you know benefit of
these enormous movie sets with a on a TV
show budget
um which was pretty cool but the things
I think well first of all they were
always brother and sister we shot a
piece I think it's it's out on Marvel
Legends on Disney plus but
um we shot a scene between Drax and
Mantis at the end of volume two where
mantis says to Drax
I you know he's my brother basically and
he's like why don't you tell him and
she's like because it's like he's
ashamed of ego and he won't love me and
so they were always brother and sister
in my mind you can see it in volume two
because you look at the the one of the
statues of all the different women that
ego has been with and there's a little
mantis woman in the back that he's been
with and so we see where she comes from
Easter egg but uh yeah that scene comes
from an Easter egg
it's an Easter egg it's a term that
maybe you haven't learned yet in your
life even though this is your job oh
yeah no I believe in Jesus I don't
believe in bunnies Okay so I'm out bye
uh
are you being serious right now yeah
okay
um
the thing I think about that scene is
that uh is you were really good in in
Palm is just so freaking good and that's
wait I'm really good and she's just so
freaking good so she's better than me
I think she's better than Easter egg
yeah that's an Easter egg that's Easter
egg your your mediocrity in that scene
is in history
so vulnerable you
that I just told you about earlier in
volume three in a movie that plays all
over the world not just a stupid TV show
whoa
yeah no you're right you're good she is
she was she was incredible I mean she
was really very vulnerable and uh she
yeah I remember that remember that yeah
she uh it's funny they remember
something about another actor what's
that yeah they did that's something I've
never that's never happened the first
time she must have been good because I
remember her and it normally I only
focus on myself what's your last name uh
mantis does she have a last name I want
you all to know that I'm grateful to
fight this side my friends
incinerate them
um you go first because you're gonna see
if I'm gonna make a joke of it
um yeah listen I it's working with you
know I told him this this is true I one
of my great joys of this whole thing has
been my friendship with Chris being able
to do this with Chris making movies is
can be really tedious at times and it's
never tedious because we always do what
we do now which is just constantly
joking around throughout the day and it
makes it really fun and I'm I am really
gonna miss that when I have to work on
other movies with other much more boring
actors probably more talented but more
boring offset
oh
go ahead you were saying no it was been
a great it's been a great collaboration
yeah it's I feel the same way it's been
great I mean we really get to play for a
living and that's the we're you're a
great Playmate is that sounds oh you
should you should run with that
you've gotten I hope that's the headline
[Laughter]
but no we get to we have a lot of fun
together and uh I'm really grateful I
mean he really I I wasn't I wouldn't say
I was plucked from complete obscurity
but on all the lists that people had of
who should play Star-Lord I wasn't on
them and he found me and and and put me
in this in this uh
this Trilogy and it really had a and I
told him this is kind of wild it was my
last audition you know another thing
though to say is that we both came from
like you know I had a fair amount of
success I had you know written you know
three number one movies I directed a
couple movies you know one of which was
very you know critically like lauded but
not you know wasn't a big movie
um and so it was like we had both had
success so We Came Upon This at the same
time of like bigger success and so we we
have been through this same experience
so you know together at the same time
um and the Guardians have done that for
both of us yeah and so that's a bond
that you can never lose even after
you've blocked their phone number we'll
all fly away together
one last time
oh
[Music]
at the end of the day Guardian volume 3
in particular is about compassion it's
about how that is an answer to most
everyone of life's problems and that you
can maybe look beyond what your own
personal beliefs are the own personal
way of looking at the world and have a
little bit of compassion for somebody
else and that makes the world a lot
easier and if people just take a little
tiny bit of that after seeing this movie
then it will be have have well worth
been
been well worth having made all three
movies right yeah that's true that's
that's great I love I love that I love
everything you said Easter egg